well here's jorge lopez's
record and numbers on the years he's two
and 11 not much run supported era just
above six
you love the strikeouts though 77
strikeouts opponents hitting 288 off of
jorge lopez
3-2 blow it by him 96.
well that's what lopez can do to you
throws the two-seamer and the four-seam
fastball this is just my best stuff at
96 pretty much
middle middle but it throws it right by
tim anderson who has had the highest
batting average
in all of major league baseball the last
three years lined out to left field
austin hayes is there and jorge lopez
goes one two three against anderson
moncada
and abreu dallas kaiko going to the
mound for his 17th start piled up 90
innings already a zra of four and a half
draymond scene of the 15 of home runs
that he has
second most on the orioles mullins with
16.
that's hit in the air right field and
deep going
back is goodwin this ball hits off the
top of the high wall mancini
has got himself a double so he got a
hanger mancini sent it the other way the
orioles with a two out man in scoring
position
there's a change-up bounce to short tim
the short way
for round number three in the o strand
two in the first inning no score
from maryland
pat shortstop first base runner for the
sox is garcia on a 3-2
single to left
andrew to right that's a base hit garcia
stops at
second not running on suntan there who
was in shallow right
so two on for the sox in the second
inning
he went around on a breaking ball so
jorge lopez picks up his second
strikeout he works around a little bit
of two out damage no score middle the
second
ramone got called up you see what he's
doing 333 a homer five rbis
and he swings and smacks this one a deep
left field this ball out of here
ramona sends it out and the orioles
strike first on this friday night well
the youngster's getting some
opportunities and he
is not wasting him his fourth home run
this season
boy he got a hanging off speed pitch
look like one of those hanging cutters
kaiko trying to get that ball
in on the hands of ramon urias and it
never got there
o2 change severino was in swing mode
when he got up off the bench and there's
one gone
he can do that he can expand his zone
with the best of it
he swings and smacks this one down the
right field line
he'll hold on at first base he hunts on
the first pitch
and the orioles another base runner with
two outs even count against savala
and lopez got him in a swing and miss it
was the elevated changeup
tim a rocket to right field that's a
base hit
so he'll start a new streak tim anderson
on base nine of the last 10 times
brian goodwin tie with tim anderson with
15
runs scored since his call-up
curveball ripped to right field down the
line the sox will at least tie the ball
game
it's an rbi for goodwin abreu into third
it's a double
and we are even at one
angle chops it to third gutierrez
throws engel out at first base but
goodwin's double
has got us tied up at one as we move to
the bottom of the third
second week of september coming in for a
weekend series and that's going to be
great
mount castle quickly a ground ball to
second base
that is a six pitch inning for dallas
kykel back to the bat rack for the socks
strength ring
well that's how you get out of a jam
right there jorge lopez rares back how
about this
95 right on the outside part of play
can't do it any better than that
we're all square 1-1 going to bottom of
the fourth
i wouldn't even use that on the ground
to third
and monkatta is going to make the peg
anyway and the out
is there that was a fair baseball down
the third base line
and two down as santander remains in
second base
two on nobody out two and two
on the ground right side and he got it
through that hole
sox take the lead for the first time in
the ball game on an abraeu rbi
single scoring anderson you can't really
just stay away to a quality run producer
and expect that you're going to come
away without giving up at least one run
jorge lopez out of the game white tigers
have a 2-1 lead
runners on first and second nobody out
difference maker for him is that
spitfinger fastball when he gets it
dancing he can rack up the strikeouts
gutierrez tough play hayes coming on and
gutierrez puts it away
kelvin gutierrez he's made a couple of
good defensive plays at the
start of this game yes he has up the
ladder to get the orioles off the field
on the ground ball
boy this is a tough one here
[Applause]
there's the ground ball tim the feed
garcia the turn and he whipped it there
for out number two
that is a spectacular piece of sleight
of hand
by leori garcia here is tim anderson
with the infield in
tim to right on a line well struck to
the wall
and off the wall one run home
gavin sheets coming as well and that
is a two-run double for tim anderson
and tim almost took it out of the park
and it's up to brian goodwin
with the sox walking four times in the
inning
fall four and the sox have a 5-1
lead on three straight walks and five
total in the inning
true driven in by goodwin on his double
and now very quietly on the walk giving
him 12 for the year
that was a slider adam pokes it to right
on a line and santander makes the catch
here comes monkatta to turn it into a
sac fly
and a good two-strike piece of lumber
for adam engel to drive in run number
six
a couple of men on one two severino took
strike three
right on the inside corner he's both
strikeouts for dallas kykel tonight
one two swinging a miss on that change
up
the steady hand of dallas kykel tonight
has worked through some trouble
very easily and it's 6-1 to the seventh
gavin sheets trying to give his family a
thrill here he walked and scored
in the sixth baltimore native gavin
sheets
deep to right field it is
up and out of here oh gavin sheets in
front of friends and family
gives it a ride and dad is thrilled 7-1
how about it that smile
will last forever we got to do his
weight back on the change it's easier
said than done but he was able to see it
he was able to do it and it's a six-run
lead the folks are pretty happy and
pretty proud
kevin sheets froze up in baltimore and
watch his family
yeah how about that jose
abreu two on two out seventh inning
oh that ball's rocked by abreu to left
field all the way to the wall
there are the two runs driven in for
abreu
and things moving along swimmingly in
baltimore
nine to one soldier tate valdez
adam angle in the air left field hayes
back at the track
it is gone cherry on top
and adam angle home run that's a dozen
tonight
[Applause]
into center field engel is there to make
the catch in the sox win
in a major way gavin's thrill 12-1
your final score the sox win in
baltimore